>> Tucker: YOU MAY HAVE MISSED
IT BUT ROBERT MUELLER INDICTED
13 RUSSIAN NATIONALED AND THREE
RUSSIAN COMPANIES EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
THE THOUGHT IS THEY WOULDN'T
SHOW UP FOR COURT.
NOW THEY'RE CONTESTING AND THE
CASE IS GOING TO COURT AND THAT
MIGHT BE BAD FOR ROBERT
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION.
HOW AND WHY?
NOBODY CAN ANSWER THOUGH
QUESTIONS MORE THAN JOSEY.
WHY WOULD THIS BE BAD TO GO TO
TRIAL?
>> BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT READY FOR
IT.
THEY INDICTED A CASE PREMATURELY
AGAINST PEOPLE THAT THEY NEVER
THOUGHT WOULD SHOW UP FROM
RUSSIA.
ONE OF THE RUSSIAN COMPANY HIRED
LAWYERS AND SENT THEM TO COURT
TO SAY WE'RE HERE AND WE WANT TO
PLEAD NOT GUILTY AND WE WANT
DISCOVERY ON YOUR CRIMINAL CASE
AGAINST US.
MR. MUELLER'S PEOPLE OBJECTED
AND SAID WE'RE NOT READY FOR AN
ARRAIGNMENT.
THEY'RE NOT HERE PROPERLY.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE SAID,
MR. MUELLER, YOU INDICTED THIS
CASE.
IT'S YOUR CASE.
IT'S GOING TO TRIAL.
LET'S START THIS PROCESS RIGHT
NOW.
GET DISCOVERY.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE SAYING HE
INDICTED PEOPLE WITHOUT BEING
READY TO PROVE THEY'RE GUILTY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HE A BECAUSED THE GRAND JURY
PROCESS AS HE HAS FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THIS OUTRAGEOUS
INVESTIGATION AUTHORIZED BY
MR. ROSENSTEIN.
THIS IS ROSENSTEIN'S MONSTER IN
SPADES.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
IT SEEMS BORDERLINE IMMORAL TO
INDICT SOMEBODY UNLESS THEY'RE
GUILTY.
>> THEY DID IT FOR ONE REASON
ONLY.
ROBERT MUELLER NEEDED SOMETHING
RUSSIAN TO MAKE HIS
INVESTIGATION LOOK GOOD.
HE INDICTED 13 PEOPLE AND
CORPORATIONS IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
THAT HE THOUGHT WOULD NEVER SHOW
UP AND BINGO, ONE OF THEM SHOWS
UP AND SAYS PROVE IT, MOTHER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN
UNBELIEVABLE STORY.
IMAGINE IF HE DID THAT TO
AMERICANS LIKE, I DON'T KNOW,
FLYNN.
>> HE ALREADY HAS.
HE DOES IT TO MR. FLYNN.
>> Tucker: UNBELIEVABLE.